now that we have our parameterization
right over here let's get down to the
business of actually evaluating this
surface integral it's a little bit
involved but we'll try to do it step by
step and so the first thing I'm going to
do is figure out what D Sigma is in
terms of SNT in terms of our parameters
so we can turn this whole thing into a
double integral with respect to or a
double integral in the s/t plane and
remember D Sigma right over here it's
just a little chunk of the surface it's
a little area of the surface right over
there and we saw in in previous videos
the ones where we where we learned what
a surface integral even is we saw that
that D Sigma right over there it is
equivalent to the magnitude of the cross
product of the partial of our
parameterization with respect to one
parameter crossed with the
parameterization with respect to the
other parameter times the differentials
of each of the parameters so this is
what we're going to use right here it's
a pretty simple looking statement but as
we'll see taking cross products tend to
get a little bit hairy especially cross
products of three-dimensional vectors
but we'll do it step by step but before
we even take the cross product we first
have to take the partial of this with
respect to s and then the partial of
this with respect to T so first let's
take the partial with respect to s the
partial of R with respect to s so right
over here all the stuff with the T in it
that's you can just view that as a
constant so cosine of T isn't going to
change the partial of or the derivative
of cosine of s with respect to s is
negative sine of s so this is going to
be equal to I'll put the negative out
front negative cosine of T sine of s I'm
going to keep everything that has a T
involved purple sine of s and let me
make I don't know I'll make the vectors
Orange I and then well plus and once
again we take the derivative with
respect to s cosine of T is just a
constant derivative of sine of s with
respect to s is cosine of s so it's
going to be plus cosine of T cosine of s
cosine of T cosine of S
cosine of s cosine of s J J and then
plus plus the derivative of this with
respect to s well this is just a
constant the derivative of v with
respect to s would just be zero this is
the same thing this is a constant with
it this does not change with respect to
s so it does so our derivative our
partial here with respect to s is just 0
so we could write even zero K right 0
I'll just write 0 K right over there and
that's nice to see because that'll make
our cross product a little bit more
straightforward now let's take the
partial with respect to T now let's take
the partial with respect to T now let's
take the partial with respect to T all
right and we get so the derivative of
this with respect to T now cosine of s
is the constant derivative of cosine T
with respect to T is negative sine of T
so this is going to be negative sine of
T cosine of s cosine of s cosine of s I
I'll do I'll go to that I'll mail use
this blue I and then plus now derivative
of this with respect to T derivative of
cosine of T is negative sine of T so
once again so now we have minus sign
like that minus sign minus sine of T
sine of s sine of s my hand is already
hurting from this this is a painful
problem J plus derivative sine of T with
respect to T we're taking the partial
with respect to T is just cosine of T so
plus cosine of T plus cosine of T and
now times the K unit vector now we're
ready to take the cross product of these
two characters right over here and to
take the cross products let me write
this down so we're going to say we're
going to take the cross product of that
with that is going to be equal to it I'm
going to set this huge matrix or it's
really just a three by three matrix so
it's going to be huge because going to
take up a lot of space to have to write
down all this stuff
so maybe I'll take up about maybe I'll
take up about that what space so that I
have space to work in and I'll write my
unit vectors up here i JK or at least
this is how I like to remember how to
take cross products of through of three
dimensional vectors take the determinant
of this of this 3x3 matrix the first row
are just our unit vectors the second row
is the first vector that I'm taking the
cross product of so this is it's going
to be negative I'm just going to rewrite
this right over here so it's going to be
negative cosine of T sine of s sine of s
and then you have cosine of T cosine of
s cosine of T cosine of s cosine of s
and then you have 0 which will hopefully
simplify our calculations and then you
have the next vector that's the third
row negative sine of T negative sine of
T cosine of s and I encourage you to do
this on your own if you already know
where this is going it's good practice
and even if you have to watch this whole
thing to see how it's done try to then
do it again on your own because this is
one of those things you really got to do
yourself to really have it sit in
negative sine of T sine of s sine of s
and then finally cosine of T cosine of T
so let's take let's take the determinant
now so first we'll think about our I
component our I component you would
essentially ignore this column the first
column and the first row and then take
the determinant of this sub matrix right
over here so it's going to be I so this
is going to be equal to I times
something I'll put the something in
parenthesis there normally you see
there's something in front of the eye
but you can swap them there so let me
just so it's going to be I times
something ignore this column that row
this determinant is cosine of T cosine
of s times cosine of T which is going to
be cosine squared of T right a little
neater cosine squared of T cosine of s
cosine of s and then from that we need
to subtract zero times this but that's
just going to be zero so we're just left
with that now we're going to do the J
component but you probably remember the
checkerboard thing when you have to
evaluate three by three matrices
positive neg
positive so you have a negative you
write a negative J negative coefficient
I guess in front of the J times
something and so ignore J's column J
zero and so you have negative cosine of
T sine of s times cosine of T well
that's going to be negative
that's going to be negative cosine
squared of T negative cosine squared of
T times sine of s let me make sure I'm
doing that right ignore that and that
it's going to be that times that so yep
negative close I'm sine of s minus zero
times that and so that's just going to
be zero so we can ignore it you have a
negative times a negative here so they
can both become a positive and then
finally you have the K component and
once again you go back to positive
they're positive negative positive on
the coefficients that's just evaluating
it three by three matrix and then you
have plus K times and now this might get
a little bit more involved because we
won't have the zero to help us out
ignore this row ignore this column take
the determinant of this sub two-by-two
you have negative cosine T sine s times
negative sine of T sine s well that's
going to be the negatives cancel out so
it's going to be cosine of T cosine of T
sine of T times sine squared of s times
sine squared of s and then from that
we're going to subtract the product of
these two things but that products going
to be negative so you subtract a
negative that's the same thing as adding
a positive so plus and you're going to
have cosine T sine T again plus cosine T
let me scroll to the right a little bit
we know that plus cosine T sine T again
and that's times cosine squared of s
times cosine squared of s now this is
already looking pretty hairy but it
already looks like a simplifications
there and that's where the colors are
helpful actually now have trouble doing
math and anything other than kind of
multiple pastel colors because this
actually makes it much easier to to see
some patterns and so what we can do over
here is we can factor out the cosine T
sine T and so this is equal to cosine T
sine T ty
times sine squared s plus cosine squared
s and this we know definition of the
unit circle this is just going to be
equal to one so that was a significant
simplification and so now we get our
cross product we get our cross product
being equal to let me just rewrite it
all our cross product R sub s crossed
with r sub t is going to be equal to
cosine squared cosine of cosine squared
T cosine s cosine s times our I unit
vector plus cosine squared T plus cosine
squared t sine of s sine of s times our
J unit vector times our J unit vector
plus plus all we have left because this
is just one cosine T sine T plus cosine
T sine T times our K R K unit vector so
that was pretty good but we're still not
done we need to figure out the magnitude
of this thing remember D Sigma
simplifies to the magnitude of this
thing times d s DT so let's figure out
what the magnitude of that is and this
is really the homestretch so I'm really
crossing my fingers that I don't make
any careless mistakes now so the
magnitude of all of this business
magnitude of all of this business is
going to be equal to the square root and
I'm just gonna have to square each of
these terms and then add them up the
square root of the sum of the squares of
each of those terms so the square of
this is going to be cosine squared
square is cosine to the fourth cosine to
the fourth T cosine squared s cosine
squared s + cosine to the fourth T sine
squared s and I already see a pattern
jumping out sine squared s + + cosine
squared T sine
squared T now the first pattern I see is
this if just this first part right over
here we can factor out a cosine to the
fourth T then we get something like this
happening again so let's do that so this
these first two terms are equal to
cosine to the fourth T times cosine
squared s plus sine squared s which once
again we know is just one so this whole
expression has simplified to cosine to
the fourth T plus cosine squared T sine
squared T now we can attempt to simplify
this again because this term in this
term both have a cosine squared T in in
them so let's factor those out so this
is going to be equal to everything I'm
doing is under the radical sign so this
is going to be equal to this is going to
be equal to a cosine squared T times
cosine squared T and when you factor out
a cosine squared T here you just have a
plus a sine squared T and that's nice
because that once again simplified to 1
all of this is under the radical sign
maybe I'll keep drawing the radical
signs here to make it clear that all of
this is still in the radical sign and
then this is really really useful for us
because the square root of cosine
squared of T is just going to be cosine
of T so all of that business actually
finally simplify to something pretty
straightforward so all of this is just
going to be equal to cosine cosine of
cosine of T so going back to what we
wanted before if we want to rewrite what
D Sigma is it's just cosine T DS DT so
let me write that down so D Sigma and we
can use this for the next part D Sigma
is equal to cosine of T DS DT and I'll
see you in the next part